uh lastly i mean i know this is kind of
a dark subject but i know you lost your
mom in 2015 to cancer yeah and i know
it's been no no no not to cancer no no
also also i appreciate that but not dark
it's not dark i i i just want to know
how you
how you deal with that because there was
a lot of dysfunction and i know you
loved your mother and i know there was a
lot of
it was tough but uh do you feel like you
still think about it do you still deal
with it is it something that you'll
always deal with or you you pretty you
feel pretty good about it no
no i i don't know man i mean look
in the midst of all of the
insanity that that was my relationship
with my mom you know for the last you
know 13 years or whatever we didn't have
a relationship i i attempted to help her
in as many ways as i could without
enabling as as much as possible which is
very difficult sometimes you know like
i mean you know at one point she was she
was basically going to go to jail or go
to uh or be homeless and you know like
you don't know what to do because your
mother is very mentally unhealthy very
mentally uh and emotionally very
unhealthy and
unless somebody like that sees
like a really hard like hits a real wall
are they ever going to recognize that
they need help and so you're putting
this weird gambit really it's like well
i don't want my mom to be homeless but i
also don't want her to keep being the
thing that would make her homeless like
in her in her unwellness
so we we danced for you know 13 years of
trying to do the best i was doing the
best i could
um
you know but uh
in that time and even after you know
when she died i wept for three days
super hard and then i stopped and i
didn't cry anymore after that until i
went to therapy
uh you know not two two years after that
thinking i had dealt with that all the
time like i didn't even when my mom was
still alive i would be like you know i
don't i don't hate my mom i don't i
don't hold anything against my mom well
i was suppressing so much [ __ ] so much
[ __ ] so i i you know if you're not
metabolizing that then you think you've
dealt with it because you've done some
mental gymnastics to convince yourself
that you have but you have to go feel
that stuff emotionally you got to
actually feel it and so it wasn't until
i went to therapy and i you know was
in connecticut those three weeks that
totally saved my life really and one of
my assignments was write a letter to
your mom and your dad and i you know it
took me 10 minutes just to start my i
was crying so hard when i first started
to write this i couldn't ten minutes
went by and i couldn't every time the
pen would go to paper i'd be like okay
i mean it was gnarled sparkly
and then um you know and then finally i
started writing it and the whole front
of this piece of paper was
[ __ ] like i can't believe you did all
these things to me and the girl my
sisters and why did you do this and you
did this and you did that and yeah
you're just really kind of venting and
getting stuff out and i flipped the page
and this was not even an intentional
thing i was thinking to do or whatever
but i flipped the page and literally
something just flipped in my mind and
all of a sudden it was empathy that
poured out and i was like
oh buddy
it was just like
but i know i know that all you did all
these things because
they were done to you because you were
abused as a girl you were abused as a
kid
and i said you know i just recognized
like you know and that's why i think
it's so important
we have to
we have to look at each other
our parents are the rest of our family
our friends society our worst enemies
the people that you would see as the
most evil in the world and you have to
see
the child in them
we have to stop and look at the child in
that person that was abused they got
different programming they came from a
different world
they go okay you're not evil
you are just you can't you this your
journey was entirely different and maybe
in your journey you were so [ __ ] up
you were so abused you were taught that
killing people is good or hurting people
or stealing from people
that's why people do these things
it's not because they're monsters it's
not because they're evil it's because
they were once abused themselves so all
of a sudden that was like the whole
second half of this letter forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness
radical
radical love radical acceptance radical
radical forgiveness man it's necessary
for all of us for this world right now i
agree with you 100 and thank you for
being so open about that